[موسيقى]
ثلاث سنوات على مجانيه المواصلات العامه
هنا في لوكسمبورج فهل حققت هذه الخطوه
الهدف المرجوه منها على ارض الواقع
[موسيقى]
كان هدف التجربه لوكسمبورجيه تقليل
الازدحام والحد من ركوب السيارات الخاصه
لكن نتيجه كانت صادمه اذ سجلت لوكسمبورج
ثاني اعلى معدل لاستخدام السيارات بين دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد بولندا ووفقا لمعهد
يوروستات فان
681 شخصا من بين كل الف شخص في لوكسمبورج
لديهم سيارات
نحن هنا في دوله صغيره وارى ان المواصلات
العامه المجانيه امر رائع لكل شخص خاصه
للاطفال كما ان ذلك يشجع على ركوب الدراجه
للوصول الى المحطه وهذا امر صحيح
ممتازه للشعب
كسهوله انا انها فكره ممتازه خاصه للسياح
اذا يمكنهم التجول مجانا واستكشاف معالم
المدينه كما ان موضوع شراء وهل هي منتهيه
الصلاحيه ام لا امر لم اعد افكر فيه مطلقا
لوكسمبورج تستقبل يوميا 220 الف عامل من
بلدان مختلفه وهو رقم يشكل نحو نصف اجمالي
عدد الموظفين في مؤسساتها وشركاتها وياتي
اغلبهم من المانيا فرنسا وبلجيكا
ثقافه السياره لا تزال تهيمن على اهل
لوكسمبورغ واستقطابهم نحو وسائل النقل
العام المجانيه مساله معقده الا ان
السائحه هو الفائز الاكبر في استكشاف قلب
اوروبا الاخضر والتنقل عبر اراضيها
لبرنامج صباح العربي ايهم القاسم
لوكسمبورج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات